y llegamos hasta la capital a belga Ahí
está nuestra corresponsal Esther Herrera
Esther la saludo muy buena tarde la otan
ya entonces ha firmado estos protocolos
de acción para que entren en Finlandia y
Suecia como los próximos miembros En qué
puntos estamos Y cuándo podría entrar en
la alianza de estos dos países Esther
Hola Buenos días Raúl la otan ya está
preparada para esta ampliación histórica
se le asegurado el secretario general de
la otania stoltenberg con una
negociación expresa apenas han durado
unas horas Porque tanto Suecia como
Finlandia ya estaban muy alineados con
los países de la alianza a partir de
ahora podrá empezar ya el proceso de
ratificación en que todos los países
miembros de la otan tendrán que aprobar
que efectivamente Suecia Finlandia serán
los próximos miembros de la otan es un
proceso que puede durar algo más de un
año normalmente aunque muchos países ya
han asegurado que empezarán a hacerlo ya
de forma rápida de hecho por ejemplo el
gobierno de Estonia ya ha asegurado que
mañana convocará de urgencia su
parlamento nacional para poder ratificar
de hecho hay muchas diferencias entre
los países sobre cómo se puede ratificar
este esta nueva ampliación aún así el
secretario general de la otan James
toltenberg ha pedido a todos los países
que el proceso sea rápido porque el
proceso de ampliación ya ha sido muy
rápido de apenas siete semanas a pesar
del veto de Turquía y Espera que esta
ratificación en lugar de un año dure
apenas unos meses con la incorporación
de estos dos países se amplía la
frontera terrestre de la otan a más de
1000 kilómetros con Rusia una frontera
que es de más de 1.000 km la que se para
Finlandia de Rusia y por lo tanto es
también un algo histórico de hecho la
otan ahora a partir de ahora considera a
Rusia una de las amenazas más directas
así lo declaró la semana pasada en
Madrid con la firma de hoy Suecia y
Finlandia Son miembros de facto porque
ahora podrán participar también en las
reuniones mientras dure todo el proceso
estherry con esto pues es todo parecía
indicar que entonces ya Turquía levantó
definitivamente sujeto para el ingreso
de estos dos países pero las cosas
podrían complicarse en un futuro por
parte de Turquía
bien Lo cierto es que hay dudas porque
la semana pasada en Madrid como ya
pudimos contar Finlandia Suecia y
Turquía llegaron a un acuerdo porque
Turquía temía que estos dos países
nórdicos estuviera protegiendo a
supuestos terroristas miembros del
partido de los trabajadores kurdos el
pkk que el gobierno Turco considera un
partido terrorista y un grupo terrorista
aún así Suecia y Finlandia se
comprometieron con un acuerdo con
Turquía
a enviar a terroristas a supuestos
terroristas a Turquía aún así tanto
Finlandia como Suecia aseguran que
seguirán todos los cauces legales para
que a pesar de que Turquía ha enviado
una lista con 73 supuestos terroristas a
Suecia y Finlandia los dos gobiernos
aseguran que cumplirán todas las normas
legales y por lo tanto no está todo tan
claro que se pueden enviar a todas estas
personas Así que ahora mismo hay dudas
de que si Turquía pudiera ahora levantar
su veto y realmente pudiera pueda
bloquear también en su parlamento la
adhesión de Suecia y Finlandia Así que
hay dudas de que finalmente pueda
producirse fácilmente este proceso de
ratificación